well hello boys and girls lemurs and
squirrels this is tim ferriss and
welcome to another episode of
the tim ferriss show this episode was
just a blast and part of me still
doesn't believe
that it happened of course my job is to
interview and deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types
of all different stripes from all
different fields and
my guest for this episode is none other
than
the icon jerry seinfeld so who is jerry
seinfeld entertainment icon jerry
seinfeld's comedy career took off after
his first appearance on the tonight show
with johnny carson in 1981. eight years
later he teamed up with fellow comedian
larry david to create
what was to become the most successful
comedy series in the history of
television
seinfeld a lot of you have heard of it
the show ran on nbc for nine seasons
winning numerous emmy
golden globe and people's choice awards
and was named the greatest television
show of all time in 2009 by tv guide
and in 2012 was identified as the best
sitcom ever in a 60 minutes vanity fair
poll
seinfeld made his netflix debut with the
original stand-up special
jerry before seinfeld along with his
emmy nominated and critically acclaimed
web series comedians in cars getting
coffee
which has garnered more than 100 million
views in which the new york times
describes as
impressively complex and artful and
variety calls
a game changer his latest stand-up
special 23 hours to kill
was released by netflix earlier this
year he is also the author of
is this anything or is this anything
it's a question with a question mark at
the end
which is a brand new book and features
his best work across
five decades in comedy it is a
collection of his
notes his journaling and certainly his
process
you can find him on twitter jerry
seinfeld instagram jerry seinfeld
facebook at jerry seinfeld and if you
have
interest in creative process gamifying
life
mastering the mind comedy
habits and systems of someone who can
operate at the top of their field for
decades
this conversation touches all of those
things please enjoy
a wide-ranging conversation with none
other than
jerry seinfeld
this episode is brought to you by aura
o-u-r-a
it is the only wearable that i wear on a
daily basis aura is the company
behind the smart ring that delivers
personalized sleep and health insights
to help you optimize
just about everything and i've tried
every device out there that you can
imagine
this one really makes the cut i've been
using it religiously for at least six
months now
and i was introduced to it by dr peter
etia who's also vetted
just about everything with advanced
sensors aurapec's state of the art heart
rate heart rate variability hrv
super important to me temperature
activity and sleep monitoring technology
into a convenient non-invasive
ring it's tiny it weighs less than six
grams and focuses on
three key insights sleep readiness and
activity so
i can use it to help focus my attention
on the type
volume intensity of exercise that i
should do in a given day
i use it to determine how certain types
of alcohol at different times of the day
affect
my sleep which they do and i can see all
of that in graph form trended over time
there are tons of actionable insights
that have come from using this ring
for me they have a number of incredible
people on
their team dr matthew walker a professor
of neuroscience and psychology at uc
berkeley
and also author of why we sleep the
mega hit is ora's chief science advisor
as just one example
the aura ring is one of the most
accurate wearables available because it
measures your vitals directly from your
finger so it's not
deducing that or making a best
guesstimate based on a bunch of other
things and trying to triangulate
compared to a medical grade
electrocardiogram the aura ring is
99.9 accurate for resting heart rate
and 98.4 accurate for heart rate
variability and i work with hrv doctors
and they recommend
that i use the aura ring so try it
yourself it is
super cool and super practical very
actionable
the aura ring comes in two styles and
three colors
silver black and matte black i use matte
black
for 299 dollars you can give or
get the gift of health by visiting
auraring.com
that's o u r a r i n g
dot com again that's aura ring dot com
this episode is brought to you by rock
form that's without a c
r r-o-k-f-o-r-m rokform is the active
lifestyle iphone and galaxy protective
case
company i've been using their stuff for
a few months now
and good god they can survive anything
first off
rokform protection is beyond great you
can find thousands of five-star reviews
and customer testimonials which the team
at rock farm calls survival stories that
include
things like a drop from the upper deck
of a baseball stadium and a 75-foot cell
phone tower fall
it's kind of unbelievable but these
cases make your phone
virtually indestructible each case is
built also around an integrated magnet
that is completely safe for your phone
the magnets are incredibly strong and
allow you to instantly attach your
device to any magnetic surface
toolboxes file cabinets refrigerators
golf carts
you name it i use it in the gym to check
my form all out of the time you can just
slap it on just about anything rokform
pioneered magnetic technology in the
mobile accessory space in 2011
and i've never seen anything quite like
these magnets
i will use mine on my peloton bike so i
can watch listen or take calls during
workouts
it fits my iphone 11 pro max perfectly
and allows me to keep my hands free for
all sorts of stuff
all their cases also come with a
built-in twist lock system that can be
used with any of rokform's optional
mounts
for bike motorcycle car and much more
these machined aluminum mounts are built
to last and are compatible with every
rokform case
so if you get a new phone or whatever
you just need a new
case and it will still attach to all of
the mounts
rokform also has a portable golf speaker
this is bluetooth
that instantly mounts to a golf cart
with mind-blowingly
strong magnets like i mentioned i don't
really golf
but i will use this bluetooth speaker to
listen to music
in the kitchen i'll slap it on the
refrigerator i will
use it in the gym and hang it from a
carabiner which is included
with the speaker and so on and so forth
so
upgrade to a rokform case today because
you have better things to hold on to you
can use your hands for other stuff
and like i mentioned these things make
your phone bulletproof
and as a special offer for tim ferris
show listeners that's you guys
get 25 off that is a good discount 25
off at rockform.com that's rokform.com
when you use promo code tim that's 25
off
at rokform.com when you use promo code
tim one more time rockform.com promo
code
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal and personality
jerry welcome to the show thanks tim
great to be here
i really appreciate you making the time
and i thought we would start
with the beginning of is this anything
and
in the suppose you could call it the
introduction of the preface
another book pops up which is the last
laugh by phil berger
and i would love to just know how that
book
entered your life how did i find that
i really don't know but but i still have
it
i have the copy that i bought wherever i
found it
i mean i was in high school and i did
the absolute minimum
you could do to to survive
in high school i never read anything
outside of high school except magazines
car magazines comic books
and esquire is uh
i don't know in those years you know um
early early 70s esquire was really
full of character and about encouraging
male boldness and inventiveness
in lifestyle and just life in general
you know they were very sophisticated
and it was everything i wanted to be
i wanted to be urban and i wanted to be
smart
and smarter than i was and i wanted to
have like this cool adventurous life and
they were very encouraging to that i
don't think there's
anything like that around today
that was essential and the same with
that book the last laugh
it was it was just like whatever
made men in centuries past become
explorers
you know i don't know how they became
that i guess i i remember
reading about explorers clubs like in
17th 18th century london
you know i have two sons
and a daughter and that's that's the
thing i really wanted
if i could pass along the two things i
would want to pass along would be ethics
and boldness in life
but that doesn't answer your question
where i got the book i don't know well
that's okay though
the genesis story is is secondary it's
really the
the context that you're providing and
just as a quick side note a friend of
mine cal fussman
used to write the what i've learned
interview series
in esquire back when i
went you know when it had and maybe
still doesn't somehow that character
that you're describing that boldness
what was it inside the last laugh that
grabbed you so much
yeah so if i look back at my whole life
starting you know about like second or
third grade
it was all this inexorable
march towards this pursuit
of the comedy arts and
there was nothing else about comedy
albert brooks did a
album who did an article in esquire
called school for comedians and it was a
parody
and i had no idea it was a parody
he grew up in l.a and he was making fun
of
what comedians might need to learn to be
comedians
and uh that was an early 70s
esquire article and i had no idea it was
a parody i mean i just oh there's a
school or i just wanted to learn
about this world and
the last laugh really took you deeply
into the world
and it is a completely
hermetically sealed world that is
frankly unrelated to the rest of the
entertainment industry
and it's really unrelated to almost all
other creative arts it is a very sealed
ecosystem the world of comedy
particularly stand-up comedy and i was
desperately
thirsty for any scrap
of data about it now you have
much like an olympic athlete of sorts
with training logs and workouts and so
on you have
45 years of hacking away as it's put in
the book's description
on yellow notepads and so on you've
preserved all of this
and i'd love to speak or to hear you
speak
more accurately a bit about your writing
process and the preparation that i did
for this i read in the new york times
and i'm just going to read this short
bit you can fact correct this
if need be but here's how it reads i
still have a writing session every day
it's another thing that organizes your
mind the coffee goes here the pad goes
here the notes go here
my writing technique is just you can't
do anything else you don't have to write
but you can't do anything
else i would love to hear you elaborate
on that because it uh actually sounds
very similar to what
the fiction writer neil gaiman has as
his first program of writing as well
yeah but but what does that look like
for you and
what do your writing sessions tend to
look like if we look back over the last
i don't know 10 years because i'm sure
it's changed over time no it hasn't
changed
it hasn't exchanged the coffee which i
didn't know about coffee
in my younger years i think i discovered
coffee
after i had kids and i didn't have time
to have
uh long meals with my friends anymore
but we could meet for coffee
and then i realized boy this coffee
really gets you talking
and i thought maybe i'll do a show
where you just talk with coffee and
that's kind of where that came from that
convenience and car show but my writing
sessions
used to be very arduous very
uh painful pushing against the wind
in in soft muddy ground
with like a wheelbarrow full of bricks
and
i had to do it because there's just
as i mentioned in the book you either
learn to do that or you
will die in the ecosystem and i learned
that
really fast and really young and that
saved my life and made my career that i
grasped the essential
principle of survival in comedy
really young and that principle is
you learn to be a writer it's really the
profession of writing
that's that's what stand-up comedy is
however you do it
anybody you can do it any way you want
but if you don't learn to
do it in some form
you will not survive and when you sit
down is it an
empty page is it bits and pieces that
you've noted
through the week as observations that
you then flesh out
what is actually in front of you when
you start what's in front of me
is um usually about
15 or 20 pages of stuff
that's in various states of development
and then there's a smaller book of just
really really random
things like um when you're on a cell
phone call
and the call drops and then you
reconnect
with the person they'll go i don't know
what happened there
as if anyone is expecting
them to know anything about the
incredibly complex
technology of a cell phone they they
offer this little
i don't know is an excuse or an apology
they go i don't know what happened there
so anyway so i don't know so that that's
an example of something in that
my little little tiny notebook that i
don't know what to do with that
but it's just so stupid to me and funny
so that to me is like a
it's like an archery target 50 yards
away
and then i take out my bow and my arrow
and i go
let me see if i can hit that let me see
if i can
create something that i could say
to a room full of humans in a nightclub
that will make them see what i see in
that
there's something stupid and funny about
that to me
that's the very very beginning
so then i'll write something about it
it'll be
if i'm lucky it'll be a half a page or a
page
on a yellow legal pad and i'll write
that
and then in the session the next day
if i get around to it i will see it
again and i'll see what i have
and what i like and i don't like and as
any writer can
tell you it's 95 rewrite
so i have two phases there is the free
play
creative phase and then there is the
polish
and construction phase of
and i i love to spend inordinate
i mean it's not wasteful to me because
that's just what i like to do
amounts of time refining and perfecting
every single word of it until it has
this pleasing
flow to my ear and then it becomes
something that i can't wait to say
and then we go from there to the stage
with it
and then from the stage the audience
will then
i i imagine you know it's a very
scientific thing to me it's like okay
here's my experiment
and you run the experiment and then the
audience
just dumps a bunch of data on you
of this is good this is okay this is
very good this is terrible
and that goes into my brain from
performing it on stage
and then it's back through the rewrite
process and then new ideas will come and
it's
you know it's just millions of different
kinds of development it's just that
so you're just trying to get your you're
just going to that place
of creating fixing
jettisoning it's extremely occupying
it's
never boring it's the frustration i'm so
used to at this point i don't even
notice it
and it's just uh work time it's just
work time which
and that's my i like the way athletes
talk about i got to get my work in did
you get your work in
i like that phrase one of the reasons i
was looking forward to doing this show
with you is i know
that it's something you are very
interested in the craft
the yeah the systemization of the brain
and creative endeavor or
you know i really think when i'm working
it's very much like when you're watching
a picture working
on stage and now we're going yep uh so
that's
different so basically it's on stage and
off stage it's
it's the desk and then the stage and
then back to the desk and then back to
the stage
and that's endless the process and the
repeatable process the experimentation
like you phrased it
is extremely interesting to me and if we
took
or take that cell phone example the
dropping of reception that's an
observation
it seems to me that you are a real
connoisseur of
questions whether those questions are
being used as part of a bit
or possibly as prompts and you mentioned
the coffee
in part leading to comedians in cars
in a harvard business review interview
you also mentioned that it's important
to know what you don't like
a big part of innovation is saying you
know what i'm really sick of
question mark right for you that was
talk shows where the music plays
somebody walks out to a desk shakes
hands with the host
sits down yeah and what am i really sick
of
being a departure point for innovation
i would love to hear about any
questions if there are questions that
you use as prompts
to help elicit observation or materials
for yourself
no no that's that part is
somewhat having a very cranky nature
and being a sensitive kind of
i don't know if it's percep perception
but
you're just provoked by a lot of things
you know yeah and that if you're lucky
enough to have that
the next thing you must do is nurture
and protect it
and never lose it and the enemy of it
is success
success is the enemy of irritability and
crankiness
because now you have money and you can
remove
the difficulties from your life and
that's not good
how do you contend with that because
you've had certainly you've
i would imagine have had to do things to
offset in that case
the creature comforts and so on that
come along with the
amount of success that you've had yes
the thing i did
that really solved almost all of that
issue is i got
married okay
please elaborate that you'll never run
out
if you get married and if you have kids
then then you've got a gold mine
you mentioned just a few minutes ago
about wordsmithing
until you get everything pleasing to the
ear
and really obsessing over the
the pros i've read that one of your
explanations for the success
of all of your television was that
quote the show was successful because i
micromanaged it every word every line
every take every edit every casting
and then later on if you're efficient
you're doing it the wrong way
there are a lot of questions i could ask
about this but i suppose one is
if you are for such a period of time
i understand the logic of it but for
such a long period of time
obsessing over the details like that did
you not find yourself at risk of
burnout or just hitting a point
of overwhelm or did that not happen to
you we're talking about the series now
or just yeah we're talking about the
series
the series well the series is a um you
know
if if you want to look at the comedy
arts is the only thing that interests me
creatively i think or the only thing i'm
any good at but
if i look at the different comedy arts
as if you know if i
was to break it down let's just say into
like
basics of stand-up comedy a television
series
or a movie i would analogize those to
different vessels on the water so
a tv series is like a pretty big boat
that you can run with a couple of people
a movie is a yacht there are so many
people
it's a beautiful thing there's a lot of
money involved
everybody wants it everybody thinks it's
the ultimate way to go across the water
and stand up for me is a surfboard it's
just you
you paddle out and you try and catch uh
the energy and you're all on your own
and
you can do it and go home and nobody but
you really even knows what happened
i think the more people you add to the
the vessel the faster you're going to
struggle to maintain
its progress through the water for sure
the tv
series got to a point we did it nine
years
and the way i was doing it that
was as far as it could go
before it was really going to
stop cutting through the water in that
beautiful way that it was doing
that's why i i pulled out of it before i
had to
before anyone wanted me to because i
didn't want to be
on a boat that was starting to struggle
i didn't want to have that experience
and i even more than that i didn't want
the audience
to have that experience i wanted to
complete
this gift to them in a way that they
would always
go oh i was given a lovely thing
one time in the 90s and it was just
lovely i wanted them to have it like
that
no excuses no if onlys
no it did go on a bit maybe longer than
it should have i didn't want to
i just wanted them to have this lovely
gift that's why i
stopped the tv series i could also
describe the tv series to you as a
weather event
that has an energy that gathers and
becomes cyclonic
but every storm blows itself out and
that that storm was about to run
out of energy and um so was i
it's the same thing because i i'm i was
at the center of the storm
and i could feel the slowing of the
cyclonic curve the funnel is that
something that
you had a role model for that something
you simply
perceived because it's very rare for
someone to step out
like rocky marciano usually they go a
bit too far they get
slapped around a bit or they end up
signing you know baseball mitts at
caesar's palace or whatever it is
did you have any model for that was that
something you decided entirely on your
own
the closest i had and i would never
compare myself
in any way shape or form was the beatles
the time frame of the beatles was nine
years
they broke up for different reasons we
had no discord on my show
like they struggled with but the portion
size
of the beatles just felt so right to me
and i thought and they were together
about nine years and we were together
about nine years
and there was something about adding
that other digit to go to ten
you know like if people said to me how
long did you do that series for if i
said
ten years i could just hear people go
wow
10 years it's just just the portion size
just felt too big
[Laughter]
is the you mentioned i guess irritation
as a wellspring of comedic material is
it irritation
or is it sensitivity in the
connotation of a very sensitive scale
where you're just
perceiving more is it a dissatisfaction
or a
irritability or is there i think your
five
senses have been made a little too
good and it's not quite comfortable
i have a friend actually two friends
it's really weird and they're married
this is a really weird story
and they both suffered from
this breakdown in their hearing
there's a bone in the hearing canal
that's i guess it's like i think it
looks like a little wishbone or
something you know there's all these
little fine bones in there yeah this
stirrup all these tiny bones
yeah so both of them the husband and the
wife
first the wife and then the husband like
six months later
it's a very rare condition so anyway
they both had to get this
very delicate surgery on their inner ear
and they replaced that bone with a piece
of titanium that's made
to do the same thing and it's
actually this fantastic cure for this
problem
and so they both have these titanium
ears now
and when they first got it their hearing
was like
too good and a little uncomfortable
for them and i think now they've
adjusted to it fine
but i've reminded me of how i feel like
my
senses are my eyes and my ears
and my skin and i just feel everything
just
a little more than i think i would even
like to
right and so that's yeah i think that's
just kind of a
genetic thing but i i don't know another
comedian that isn't
the same and just has this hair trigger
reaction to anything that is irritates
them
and a lot of it is visual i think i
think i mentioned that in my
introduction that i think jokes come
from a
kind of intense visual acuity you did
yeah so i think that's part of where it
comes from
if we imagine uh we meaning a lay
audience imagines
comics in our minds eyes
you have these sort of hypersensitive
cat-like
creatures who might be very difficult to
put into any type of group
yes but yet you mentioned a lack of
discord
on the show which i'm not a hollywood
wonk but i have a little bit of mileage
and that seems to be
not altogether common to what would you
attribute
that lack of discord i don't like
discord
and i don't like it and i
am fearless in rooting it out and
solving it
and if anyone's having a problem
i'm gonna walk right up to them and go
is there a problem let's talk about this
because i cannot
stand that kind of turmoil that approach
to
conflict resolution is very proactive
it's not like you're being passive
aggressive it's not like you're conflict
avoidant
is that something you got from your
parents is that something that you just
came out of the womb
having that direct addressing of
of discord or problems i don't know
where i got that i feel like
if you break the human struggle down
into one word it's confront
and so i kind of approach everything
that way
and just the act of the confront is like
you know what what do people always say
like admitting you have a problem all
that nonsense but
i did read some pop psychology books i i
was very much a searcher
in my younger years yoga and
zen and a little scientology
transcendental meditation
buddhism you know i i read a lot of
stuff looking i don't know what i was
looking for
i think i was i i was looking for a
working philosophy i think is what i was
looking for
in life to apply and i kind of
formed my own little i don't know if
religion is the right word but i've
definitely
created my own belief or
operating system i i think operating
system would be the best term
for what i've created because it's very
pragmatic
it's not faith-based in any way
but that's my one of my biggest
principles is
confront
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on
fifty percent five zero percent of your
returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested
in a long-term automated investment
portfolio wealthfront pioneered the
automated investing movement sometimes
referred to as robo advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
it takes about three minutes to sign up
and then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you
at an incredibly low cost wealthfront
software constantly monitors your
portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
are there any other examples that you
could give from your operating system
any other guiding rules or principles
or anything that's stuck from that
seeking period well
my guiding rule is systemize what's the
problem
the problem is like my daughter my
daughter is very
creative she's extremely bright she's
got an incredible head on her shoulders
and
i see myself in her at that age she's
way farther advanced than i was
at that age but she doesn't know i i
said to her you
she has a creative gift okay so i say to
her when you have a creative gift
it's like someone just gave you a horse
now you you have to learn how to ride it
you got to learn how to ride this horse
and
i've seen people that are born by the
dozens and dozens i've seen
people that were given black stallions
and
it usually kill if you if you have a
black stallion like from that movie
and you're born and they just put you on
it and that's what happens
they just put you on it and you either
learn to ride this thing
or it's gonna kill you then we have many
many
examples of that so she's trying to
write this thing she's struggling
i can't write i keep putting it off
so i explained to her my basic system
which you already talked about at the
top of the show
which is if you're going to write make
yourself a writing session
what's the writing session i'm going to
work on this problem
well how long are you going to work on
it don't just sit down with an
open-ended i'm gonna work on this
problem that that's a ridiculous
torture to put on a human being's head
it's like you're gonna hire a trainer to
get in shape and he comes over
and you go how long is the session and
he goes it's open-ended
forget it i'm not doing it
it's over right there you've got to
control
what your brain can take okay
so if you're going to exercise god bless
you and that's the best thing in the
world you can do
but you got to know when's it going to
end when's the workout over
it's going to be an hour okay or you
can't take that let's do 30 minutes okay
great
now we're getting somewhere i can do 30.
i'm trying to teach my son who knows how
to do transcendental meditation
how to do it i assume you know about
that i do
yeah yeah practice i can't do it 15
minutes like okay let's do 10.
let's do 10. let's come up with
something you can do that's where you
start everything that's how you start
to build a system so my daughter so i
said to her
you have to have an end time to your
writing session
if you're gonna sit down at a desk with
a problem
and do nothing else you gotta get a
reward for that and the reward is the
alarm goes off and you're done
you get up and walk away and go have
some cookies and milk
you're done if you have the guts and the
balls to sit down and write
you need a reward at the other end of
that session which is stop
now pencils down so that's the beginning
of a system
that to me will help almost anybody
learn to write
which is something you know i kind of
wanted to teach
in a way because i find it i think it's
so simple i think exercise is pretty
simple too
and but people don't they don't come up
with
good simple little systems they just try
and do it
and that's to me that's you're going to
fail the simple doesn't mean
easy and no no not easy so important
the incentives right having a reward
having
a defined format how long did your
daughter end up
choosing for her writing duration or how
long have you chosen
i told her just do an hour that's a lot
she says i'm going to write all day no
you're not nobody writes all day
[Laughter]
shakespeare can't write all day it's
it's torture
yeah if you taught a class on writing
what other lessons might you have or
resources or anything exercises cause
i'm imagining that your daughter could
sit down she says all right i have an
hour
and then you ask her how her writing
session went she said well i didn't have
any idea what to write so you'd have i
don't know what age the students would
be in your course
but what else would be a component of
your
class on writing well i would teach them
to learn to accept your mediocrity
you know no one's really that great you
know who's great
the people that just put tremendous
amount of hours into it it's a game of
tonnage
you know how many totally are you gonna
work
per week per month per year
you might even want to chart that or
with your exercise if you want to get in
shape
i couldn't get in shape i was like i
could start as a jogger you know
like in the 70s and i would run three
miles a day and then i got older and i
got married late and i had young kids
and i really had to get in shape and i
picked up this book
by bill phillips called body for life
body for life yeah and it's
really really so it's such a
system for a primitive you know brain
i do it to this day i think it's a work
of genius
this book and it really got me in shape
because he broke it down to here's what
we're going to do
in minute one here's what you're gonna
do to minute five
minute twelve and this is gonna end in
the 45 minutes or whatever it is
and every minute i know exactly what i'm
doing yeah and that
like turned the key for me and all of a
sudden i was getting in shape i never
had to ask what am i doing now
or what are we doing next it was very
it's like you gotta treat your brain
like a dog you just got you got it
it's so stupid the brain the mind is
infinite in wisdom the brain is a stupid
little dog
that is easily trained
[Laughter]
do not confuse the mind with the brain
the brain is so easy to master you just
have to
confine it you can find it yeah
and it's done through repetition and
systemization
so let's talk about feedback in the
experimental
loop that you mentioned earlier which
was
desk stage desk stage desk stage one
form of feedback
would be audience feedback and i'm
curious
what other forms of feedback you have
now there is no other feedback
that means anything okay got it well
i'll tell you
here's a here's a little a fine point of
writing technique that i'll pass along
to your writers out there
never talk to anyone about
what you wrote that day that day
you have to wait 24 hours to ever
say anything to anyone about what you
did
because you never want to
take away that wonderful
happy feeling that you did
that very difficult thing that you
tried to do that you accomplished it you
wrote you sat down and wrote
so if you say anything it's like the
same reason i don't ever heard the thing
like
you never tell people the name you're
gonna give the baby
sure until it's born because they're
gonna react and the reaction
is going to have a color and if you've
decided that that's going to be the
baby's name you don't want to
know what anybody else thinks so i will
always wait 24 hours before i
say anything to anyone about what i
wrote so you want to preserve that good
feeling because if you if let's say you
write something and you love it
and then later on that day you're
talking to someone and you thought hey
what do you think of this idea
uh blah blah blah and they don't love it
now that day feels like uh i guess you
know that that was
uh wasted effort right you always want
to reward yourself
the key to writing to being a good
writer
is to treat yourself like a baby very
extremely nurturing and loving and then
switch over to lou gossett an officer
and a gentleman
and just be a harsh prick ball busting
son of a [ __ ] about that is just not
good enough that's got to come out
or it's got to be redone or thrown away
so flipping back and forth between those
two
brain quadrants is the
key to writing when you're writing
you want to treat your brain like a
toddler
it's just all nurturing and loving
and supportiveness and then when you
look at it the next day
you want to be just a hard ass and you
switch back and forth
when you had come off stage and
feel like you had really nailed the set
you just killed
yeah would you ask for
feedback from other comics who you might
respect who are there
would you do something to celebrate
instead you're not feedback
you don't need to you don't need to ask
the the professionals that's the
that's the paradise of stand-up comedy
you don't have to ask anyone anything
stand-up comics receive a
score on what they're doing more often
and more critically than any other human
on earth you know even a pitcher he's
not on the mound
for an hour and 20 minutes straight
you know right having his pitches judged
by the umpire
and by the way some of those calls are
opinions
of the umpire that may or may not be
true every opinion the audience gives
you
is 100 accurate
right how they feel is fact suffer that
pain or have that advantage
when you did well much like after
checking the box of doing an hour-long
writing session would you
reward yourself or was that not part of
the
process for you i reward myself
constantly i mean but there's no greater
reward
than that state of mind that you're in
when that set is working
if you can extricate yourself from
your self which is the goal
in all sports and performance arts
if you get out of your mind and are able
to just function
you know your sense technique that you
have
there is no greater reward but you know
if you want to have an ice cream sundae
go ahead
it's gonna it's gonna pale in comparison
yeah did you have a long-term
plan let's just if we go back to the the
early days
did you have any type of long-term
career plan for yourself or was it
really
the ball in front of you and executing
on that one next step
and then the career emerged from that
approach or something else
are you asking me if i had a backup plan
if stand up didn't work out
is that what you do no i'm asking you if
you had a long-term career plan with the
career world
i didn't even know if you could make a
living as a stand-up comedian unless
you know you were george carlin so i
didn't i didn't know anything about it i
didn't
and the truth was there really wasn't
there really wasn't a a world like an
infrastructure
that like exists today we didn't know if
there was any jobs out there even if we
were able to learn how to do it
we had no idea what we were doing it was
completely
blind leap of faith out of the plane
with the
parachute hoping there wasn't laundry in
there
what is the feeling i mean you mentioned
it i would love
as someone who is hypersensitive for you
to describe that feeling that would make
an ice cream sundae superfluous right
that feeling of getting that feedback
what is it in the body what is it or in
the mind
however you want to answer that what
does it feel like to you i
i sometimes will describe it as math and
music
which is kind of the same thing music is
so mathematical
as is stand up is extremely mathematical
so you know i mean i i certainly don't
have to
tell you what that you're just looking
for a state of mind
you're trying to maneuver yourself into
a state of mind
that you know is your highest function
level
but there are many levels below that
that are good enough to get the job done
so that you can call yourself a
professional
so that's all there is you know is it's
musical it's very rhythmic and musical
it is for me i'm looking for the
to get myself in a rhythm and then to
get the audience in in a
rhythm very much like a conductor i
think would feel
you know a conductor has a piece of
music i have a piece of music in front
of me
and now i have to get the symphony to
be doing it the way we know it can be
and then the audience comes along and
supports that and it's this
absurd struggle and i really think
being a conductor or a surfer is the
best analogy because the forces that
you're
attempting to corral are so much greater
than you
the wave has so much more strength than
you have
all you can hope to do is navigate
within it
that's the goal to just get to that
very brief very transitory
perception of mastery it seems in this
moment
that i am completely mastering this
audience
but it's only a moment it's only a
moment i couldn't stay up there
very long even an hour is not a long
time
totally you know it's not a long time
and it takes
years and years and years of work and
study and practice
to be able to do that to do the hour the
hour is really the standard
in my business a lot of people can do
20.
some can do 35 a lot of really good guys
at 45.
an hour hour 15 i i think again
i'll go to my favorite uh which is
baseball for analogies it's the complete
game
can you finish the game and that's
that's the hour 10 hour 20.
that's nine innings of mastery
yeah you need to have not just a lot of
material but a lot of practice
and tonnage as you put it to perform at
a high level for that period of time and
and manage their energy and yours
it has totally it has to ebb and flow
and that's just to piggyback on the
analogy used a very much
similar sports and i've had a lot of
athletes on the show and
even some surfing legends like laird
hamilton they'll say they should
call surfing paddling because that's
what you're actually doing most of the
time
you get to show at the end of the day is
the cover shot surfing the big wave but
that's really the output of
a lot of tonnage right and i know you
you've been quoted as thinking of
yourself more as a sportsman than
an artist and for a lot of athletes
routine is
is super key to managing energy
and putting in the reps and producing
good results
there's a quote from you in the new york
times and the quote is i'm not ocd but i
love routine
i get less depressed with routine aside
from the writing
sessions are there any other routines
for you that are particularly important
as scaffolding or automatic behaviors
yeah exercise weight training and
transcendental meditation
i think i could solve just about
anyone's life
and i don't care what you do with weight
training
and transcendental meditation i think
your body needs that stress
that stressor and i think it builds your
the resilience of the nervous system
and i think transcendental meditation is
the
absolutely ultimate work
tool i think the stress reduction is
great but it's more the energy recovery
and the concentration fatigue
solution which is of course you know as
a stand-up comic i can tell you my
entire life is concentration fatigue
whether it's writing or performing my
brain
and my body which is the same thing are
constantly hitting the wall
and if you have that in your hip pocket
you're columbus with a compass
[Laughter]
chatting with hugh jackman on the
podcast and he's also
a devout seems like an odd word to use
since it's it can be used
quite secularly but proponent of
tm how many times what does your weekly
schedule look like
for weight training when do you do it
and do you do tm twice a day or do you
i do it uh at least twice a day but i
will do it anytime i feel like i'm
dipping
energetically yeah yeah any and yeah
if i sit down and the pen doesn't move
for like 20 minutes i know i'm out of
guess
why isn't the pen moving my weight
training routine is three times a week
for an
hour a session but i'm
into that i've been into that you know i
mentioned the bill phillips uh
body for life uh the the hit training
so it's three times a week of weights
and three times a week the uh
interval cardio training there are a lot
of days so i want to cry
instead of do it because it really it
really physically hurts but
i just think it's balancing it's very
balancing to the
forces inside humanity that i think are
just they overwhelm us we are
overwhelmed by our own power
and you gotta put that ox in the plow
make it do the stuff that it doesn't
want to do it just keeps it
what the hell do oxes do in the wild i i
can't imagine they were happy
checking twitter just developing
neuroses
you know put put it in the harness keep
i mean i
i don't know a lot of my life is i don't
like getting depressed i get depressed a
lot
i hate the feeling and these routines
the these very difficult routines
whether it's exercise or writing
and both of them are things where it's
like it's
it's brutal that's another thing i was
explaining to my daughter
she's she's frustrated that writing is
so difficult
because no one told her that it's the
most difficult thing in the world
it's the most difficult thing in the
world is to write
people tell you to write like you can do
it like you're supposed to be able to do
it
nobody can do it it's impossible the
greatest people in the world can't do it
so if you're gonna do it you should
first be told what you are attempting to
do
is incredibly difficult one of the most
difficult things there is
way harder than weight training way
harder
what you're summoning trying to summon
within your brain and your
spirit to create something onto a blank
page
so that's another part of my
systemization technique
learn how to encourage yourself
that's why you don't tell someone what
you wrote be proud of yourself encourage
you know treat yourself well for having
done that
horrible horribly impossible thing i
would have to imagine and maybe this is
just a projection because i i hope that
when i have
kids which i don't have yet that this
will be true for me but that
being kind to your creative self and
offering
positive reinforcement for yourself
through the process would affect how you
parent i would have to imagine
yes yes unfortunately we seem to have
lost the lew gossip side of parenting
pesky child protective services yeah
what do they know
[Laughter]
but yeah it is similar you want to be
very encouraging
but you also want to explain there are
laws in life that you need to know about
or you
it's gonna hurt i think one of the
better lines i've come up with
over my life is that pain
is knowledge rushing in to fill a void
with great speed
can you say that one more time please
pain is knowledge
rushing in to fill a void you don't know
that that
post of your bed was not where you
thought it was but when your foot hits
it that knowledge
is going to come rushing in really fast
it's going to really hurt when your foot
hits that post
because that was a piece of knowledge
that you didn't have
that you're going to get you're about to
get you're talking about black
black stallion and learning to ride
black stallion lest
you be broken yourself by your
superpowers
slash potential murderers i've struggled
with depression for decades
and have found some respect in the last
five or six years for a whole host of
reasons but
aside from the writing and weight
training is there anything else
that has contributed to your ability to
either stave off or
mitigate depressive episodes or manage
no i still get them still got them
the the best thing i ever heard about it
was that it's
part of a kit that comes with a creative
aspect to the brain that a tendency to
depression
seems to always accompany that and i
read that like 20 years ago and
that really made me happy so i realized
well i wouldn't have all this
other good stuff without that that's
just comes in the kit
that you have a tendency to depression
but i i think it's fair to say that
i don't know a human that doesn't have
the tendency i'm sure it varies
i have a number of friends who are in
comedy and a lot of them are afraid of
getting any type of treatment or taking
antidepressants because they
worry that it would rob them of their
comedic
insight i don't know if that's something
you've run into
yourself or is it more that you accept
it as a natural
byproduct or companion to the
sensitivity i i would agree with a
chemical intervention and to
stabilize your mood i would be nervous
about that
also and besides which as you know
as we all know there are many other
better
remedies that you know
basically a pair of running shoes is
probably better than any of the
drugs they have on the market depending
on the severity of course
yeah or at least make sure that you're
adding those
elements into your life since i think we
all know people who take antidepressants
and are still depressed so it's
worthwhile to tick off the bigger boxes
uh behaviorally speaking i don't think
depression is really a creative source
i i think irritability and crankiness is
right but not depression depression is
just an annoying thing we have to deal
with
you give me a quote i'll ask you one
more question and then uh we can
we can go a little more i'm enjoying
this
so much let's go all right let's do it
so i'd love to ask about
following up on depression i'd love to
ask about failure
just to keep this bright and shiny uh
can you think of
how a particular failure or a parent
failure set you up for later success
in other words do you have a favorite
failure of any type something that
seemed catastrophic at the time that in
fact
set you up for great things later
yeah yeah i have a couple really good
ones
and there's another thing i try and
teach the kids you know when something
horrible happens and i
think of all the things i would trade
if you could take your experiences and
and ask to trade them in
the last ones i would trade would be the
failures
those are the most valuable ones when i
uh moved to la i was only doing
comedy four years but i had built up a
pretty good
reputation in new york and new york was
really in those days still very much the
miners
to la which was the majors and so i went
out to la
and people talked that i was coming and
that i was
you know one of the hot guys coming out
of new york and i was only doing it four
years i was
you know 25 years old i mean i
really still just starting and the
comedy store
was the club in la that you had to break
into
that that was the club and the guys that
worked there and the women were killers
i mean these people
made the room just shake with laughter
it was
very intimidating to go on there
and i went on there and i did very well
you know in those days you would you
would call and they would give you spots
if you were good
and i would never get spots i would get
like one spot a week and
you know one spot a week it's like one
push-up a week it's like
you get it well don't even bother so i
asked to meet with mitzi shore who's the
owner of the club and
person who ran the whole thing there and
she said to me
she said i'm the kind of person that
needs to get stepped on
and uh that's what you need you need
someone to step on you
and i'm gonna be that person
and uh she said if you called and said
if i had four spots available and you
called in i would give all four spots to
this other guy she mentions this other
guy
and i sat there in her office and i
nodded
[Laughter]
i nodded and i said well i won't mention
the name of the guy she said she was
going to give the four spots to
i said well if maybe he can't do all
four
i'd be happy to take any of the ones he
can't do
and i walked out of there and i never
worked at the comedy store again
and saying you're not working at the
comedy store in la it's like saying i
want to be a
baseball player but not the majors not
the majors in the united states
i'm going to prime my trade someplace
else
lithuania yeah and so
from there i i went from i hope it
doesn't sound immodest from being
absolutely at the top of the heap in new
york city
to playing at discos in the basement
in l.a you know to like eight people
but my resentment and hostility to her
i was a guy who i would say i was a a
three day a week guy
in terms of my writing discipline in
those days
and i went from three days a week to
seven right there
and i was like okay we're not this is
this is uh
i was angry i was angry i was frustrated
i was resentful but i used that it was
just
fuel for me she wasn't stopping me
nobody was gonna stop me
but when someone is that hostile to you
that can be a very good thing
if you're tough if you're tough enough
to eat that
[ __ ] and say i'm i'm she's not stopping
me
that's a great story i it makes me think
one of my friends alexis ohanian
co-founded reddit
and at one point early on they were
super excited about
of course their company their baby they
put all of their waking hours into it
and they met with some yahoo executive
who was basically just fishing for
inside information
and at some point in the meeting this
exec said
oh there's your traffic oh that's a
rounding error for us and
so alexis and his gut and his guys took
a huge
they made a poster that said you are a
rounding error and put it on the wall
in their office yeah
it worked it worked so what then
transpired after you went from three
days a week to seven days a week when
did you get
a glimmer of hope or
vindication the tonight shows saw me
and every comedian in the world wanted
to get on the tonight show
in the 70s and 80s it was the only way
out
of the clubs to real gigs
was to be on the tonight show the clubs
was you're working for free
right free zero
you know that's not really the object
the object is to get paid
it's obvious to be a professional so
and you're when you're on the tonight
show you're going from the service road
to lane one
no more no more apple base yeah in five
minutes
and i and i told that story in the book
too
what that felt like you know my favorite
sporting thing i mean i'm a
baseball maniac but the hundred meters
in the olympics is a as this thing i
i love i love the hundred meters and
that's what happened when you did the
tonight show in those days
you i i when i see lindsey vonn at the
top of a mountain or i see
those guys kicking their legs when
they're in the blocks you know i know
what that feels like
i know and i'm very grateful
that i know that you know if you're an
adrenaline junkie which i
am there's no good comedian that isn't
that's a big treat in life
to know how that feels that i'm gonna
change my whole life
in the next three minutes how many times
did you rehearse
that three-minute segment
of material i mean i would imagine you
must have done it a thousand times
before you
thousand yeah did you ever
have another conversation with mitzi
shore or did
any did you ever convey any message to
her or
have any communication i i did when i
got my tv series in the 90s
i moved up to this fantastic house in
the hollywood hills that overlooked all
of la
every day i would drive down the hill to
go to the studio to work on the show
i would see mitzi taking her walk on a
nearby street
that we happen to have in common and i
would always
give her a nice look
i wouldn't waver hunk but uh our eyes
melt
[Laughter]
new minutes
and you know what maybe she was right
maybe i did need someone to step on me
why did she respond that way that just
seems so
aggressive did you do anything because i
would never be
the broken the type of broken winged
bird
that she wanted to have in her little
chicken coop of dysfunction that was the
comedy though
in those days i was not built like that
the only real i want to be a stand-up
comic is because i wanted to say
to myself and to the world i don't need
you
i can do this myself and the comedy
store was
filled with people that needed her
the comedy world in those days was a
druggie yeah it's a very dysfunctional
world the comedy world because
you're taking these people that that
that can't fit in they can't
you know they have this one skill and
then you put them in the
situation where they can get anything
they want
if so whatever dysfunctional chemical
sexual you're lazy you're broken you're
messed up you know now you got you have
no structure around you to fix it
yeah you know what i mean you're out in
the world
you're completely on your own yeah it's
designed to break human beings
stand up comedy it's a perfect way to
break
a person psychologically you know i've
only been to the comedy store
once i was brought there by a friend and
i went into one of the back rooms i'm
sure you would know the name of this
room
but they listed off a whole lot of old
names
i want to say sam kinnison and a bunch
of others and they said this is where
they used the
this was the green room blah blah blah
blah blah and there was this huge
table with a mirror top with thousands
of
scratches on it and not from fingernails
right and you just think
oh my god if you don't have rails to
stay on
i mean pun intended i guess the
environment is just
designed to destroy and
yes but that's part of the fun
also the moguls if you
it's like you're a fish in the hudson
it's it's it's a toxic
environment the treatment it's just the
attrition
is brutal you never have to say
i don't get why people like this
comedian don't worry don't worry
you don't have to comment on it the
the environment itself will correct it
is a self-correcting
ecosystem of pure toxic water
[Laughter]
the self-sufficiency or desire for
self-sufficiency that you gave voice to
the
proving to others that you don't need
that you can do it on your own
seems to be a very sharp contrast to a
lot of
entertainers i know including comics who
seem to have a lot of codependency right
like they
need the audience to validate
like they need life support if they had
respiratory collapse
and was that perspective and that
character or constitution rare
i i have to say the constitution is is
kind of rare
but i also have to say i don't know
anyone who made it
over a long period of time that didn't
have it
yeah and that's another thing that kind
of led me to that
leads me to the weight training aspect i
think
it i think it builds your constitution
mm-hmm yeah
the weight training you know i just want
to give credit where credit is due
with bill phillips i read that book long
time ago this is before my second book
which was on physical performance and i
was
really impressed because it is to me
first and foremost a book about
behavioral modification and
behavioral psychology and it really
nails
those elements really really well and
you know if i think back across you know
the hundreds of interviews on this
podcast
whether it's bob iger in the world of
business and
heading disney or an athlete or
otherwise if you look at the people who
have
really performed at a high level for
decades
weight training seems to be one of the
constants or one of the near constants
yeah because you're deteriorating you're
just trying to bend that
curve a little bit you know i'm 66 i
shouldn't be
performing at this level at 66. i should
be over
so you have to you have to cheat the the
biology
yeah 66 i never i mean i suppose i could
have tried to do the math i never would
have guessed
do you just wake up some days and find
that number to be unbelievable to you or
is it a foregone conclusion i guess
because you're in your own body and go
year by year i i find it i find it funny
and i i find it very it really makes the
game
fun because i know this should not be
happening i am getting away with murder
so i love it really makes it
that's another thing i i believe we've
talked about systemizing gamifying is
another thing i'm very big on
let's make this into a game you know
whatever the problem is let's make it a
game
to me it's a fun game i i honestly you
know
i wouldn't say this around my family but
i don't care if i drop dead tomorrow
it's like i just wanted to i still feel
like
i played the game well you know yeah
that's all i want to feel i just want to
feel like i played the game well
what would be an example of gamifying i
mean i've read
of course the about the you know
seinfeld's productivity secret
marking the crosses on the calendar
which i guess yeah some people yeah
that's not really a game yeah that's
more based that
i think stats are good if you want to
improve
anything my trainer adam wright and i
always like to play this game well this
was the maximum amount of weight
you did three months ago for this many
seconds or whatever
and then it's like that's so it's a game
now let's see if i can
keep the reps going for 30 seconds last
time was 25.
so it's a little game it's just again
this goes back to my
the human brain is a schnauzer it's just
a stupid little
contraption that you can easily trick
as soon as you tell me i did it 25
seconds last time okay
let's see if i can do 30. yeah that's
not wisdom
that's not intelligence it's a stupid
little machine
it's gonna do that every single time
every time you tell someone
your last best was 25 seconds you're
gonna try for thirty
thinking back to the what ox do when
they're not in a yoke
uh and how disquiet they would be if
they were checking twitter all day
yeah yeah in the world of dog training i
know like a couple of really high level
dog trainers and
one of the expressions you hear it's
kind of this mantra like you would find
in the military or something which is a
tired dog is a happy dog
and just ensuring that your dog is
properly exerted right now oh yeah i
think there's a lot
to that as a human also yeah
so if if you're looking at gamification
in the let's just say the fitness realm
are there other ways that you've applied
that to your creative or professional
work
i guess you have these logs so in a way
i mean you have
yeah but i don't believe i don't score
myself
creatively i don't believe in that this
kind of gets into
my thoughts on material i don't know if
this will
illuminate this for you but one time
i love to go on stage at gotham and
hearing about the
vaccine today got me very excited that
maybe i'll be going back there soon
on the 23rd street in the in the city
and that's where i like to play with
material so i always i'll go there and
i'll
and i'll go on stage i'll do 20 or 30
minutes of just working on material
and then i like to take questions from
the audience you know when i'm when i
perform
for gigs the audiences are too big to
really take questions
it's too difficult but but in a room of
a couple of people you can take
questions
so one night this guy says to me um he
says when you go back to the same city
twice do you ever worry that they're
gonna
see the same show you did last time or
how do you know what you did
and how do you know when it's time to
take a piece of material
out of your act that you've been doing
it too long
and it needs to be retired and you
should do something else and
you know and these are kind of
reasonable questions uh from a uh
a regular person and i said uh so these
pieces i
i was doing tonight i said do you think
that you could think of things
similar to this and the guy says oh
god no not in a million years and i went
yeah that's what i was thinking
so what the the me the point of that
story is
if i'm going on stage and i'm doing
these bits
however long it took me to figure this
stupid bit out
you know and however many years i've
been doing
which i don't even know just be glad i'm
doing that
you know because it's a good thing
it's a good thing so this goes to my
nurturing
side of the equation if you're getting
on stage and standing in front of a
group of strangers and trying to make
them laugh
god bless you i don't give a [ __ ] what
you do
i don't care if it's old stuff new stuff
i don't care if you're dirty if you're
clean if you're going to stand up there
by yourself and try and make me laugh
i love you and i'm not going to
criticize
anything you do beyond that i'm not
going to criticize it
and you shouldn't criticize yourself
either so in other words there's no
to go back to do i gamify it no it's
always a win if i got up there and tried
to do it
i win yeah even if i didn't reach
what i'm trying to reach even if i
to me it's like a four out of ten show
i still pat myself on the back for it
still a win
damn it's still the one when you hear
the word
successful who comes to mind for you
and why could be parents could be
outside appearance could be anybody but
for you
when you hear that word is there anyone
who is really a
sort of paragon of what you would
consider success or someone you
have looked up to as someone who was
successful
wow that's a pretty broad hyper
hyperbroad it comes down to kind of how
you define it
also you know i i think i don't know if
i mean it as a joke but
i say a lot these days survival is the
new success
and yep and
i'm a big uh look tim what do you want
me to tell you in my business
if you're 60
plus or i'll even if you're 55 and
you're getting
paid to work paid well
you have crushed it yeah so
stand-up comedy you know this i i would
i would move this piece of our
conversation next to the
toxic ecosystem of of this world
when you have seen the attrition that i
have seen
it's like in the heart of the sea you
know that book
yep uh ron howard made the movie when
when they're dropping like flies
and and the the the handful the small
handful somebody asked me the other day
how many people who whose careers
were made on the tonight show with
johnny carson are still working
i didn't want to answer the question so
longevity
is what i because because you had it you
know what i mean you had it
you had you you had it so
once you have it you can only lose it
you know you can only fail to take care
of it
and that's when we get to health
and work ethic and
managing yourself so that you don't
break
because they're trying to break you i
always tease my friend jimmy fallon
that this is like a sick experiment
these talk show
gigs let's take a human being
put him in a studio for decades
doing an hour of television a day and
let's see what breaks
it's it's sick it's a sick human
experiment
like it's like a pope job who it's like
they just do it till you're dead
the forever skinner box oh god yeah
yeah that's beautiful brittle now i mean
there's a fantastic book about stand up
that i read during the virus called
seriously funny and the guy he writes
only about comedians of the 50s and 60s
and the introduction of that book which
is like 20 pages long
and he goes through woody and lenny and
joan rivers and all these great people
and how it broke one after the other
one after the other was broken by it
that they either were worn out
or their brains cracked or their
psychology cracked
or you know it just took them apart it's
a
very very difficult profession to
sustain in
so just to survive to me is the game
that's my concept of success did you
beat them at their game
they're they're they're just they
designed this thing to kill you
trap the travel you realize what it
takes to
travel to go to the airport
you know in your 50s in your 60s to fly
on planes
to go to strange cities to go to hotels
to put on a suit
to go out on stage at 8 o'clock at night
and run around and yell you know
and project your physical energy for an
hour in front of thousands of people
they're trying to kill you
[Laughter]
so i have made it into a game like
it's it's like mitzi i'm gonna step on
you and i went no no
i'm gonna step on you
[Laughter]
i suppose that's the game we're playing
that's life
life is they're trying to kill you you
get this free ride
till you're let's be generous 43
and then god goes you know what i'm
going to move on
to the people in their 16 to 23
and i'm going to give them my best if
you want to hang around you can hang
around
but i'm not giving you anything anymore
it's on you now
if you want to stick around guys but i
got nothing for you
okay you you figure it out so this
this caught my attention because i'm
exactly 43.
perfect oh yeah
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna ask you to
leave but i i got nothing for you
[Music]
seriously fine i'm gonna start giving
these 15 year old girls
amazing stuff and the boys i'm going to
give them crazy bodies that that's my
focus
my focus is 15 year olds turning them
into
super humans you i'm with you yeah
i'm the eight foot sturgeon in the
hudson barely
limping along yeah uh no one's going to
ask you to leave but
we're not giving you anything no food
no help there was no help survival is
the new success
uh i'll uh yeah if you have time for one
or two questions then we'll well i can
bring this to a close i need to go do
some
interval training eat some lentils this
is a question that sometimes hits
a dead end and i'll take the blame for
that if it does you've already given
a bunch of possible answers to this but
if you had a billboard
metaphorically speaking that could get a
message a quote an image
question anything out to billions of
people
what might you put on that billboard
back in the 80s i had a friend
who was teaching a comedy course at the
improv
melrose in la and he asked me if i would
come in and talk to the class
and i said sure i went in and there was
like
i don't know maybe 20 people in the
class in the app it was in the afternoon
and i went up on stage and i said the
fact that you have even signed up for
this class
is a very bad sign for what you're
trying to do
the fact that you think anyone can help
you
or there's anything that you need to
learn you have
gone off on a bad track
because nobody knows anything about
any of this and if you want to do it
what i really should do is
i should have a giant flag behind me
that i would pull a string and it would
roll down
and on the flag it would just say two
words
just work
[Laughter]
just work just work
yeah i love it well that is
i think an excellent place to wrap up
jerry people can find you
on all the socials twitter instagram
facebook at jerry seinfeld
the new book is is this anything which
features
your best work across five decades
that's nuts in comedy and it's a
fascinating book and a hell of a ride i
highly recommend people
check it out for anyone who's a student
of creative process
doesn't have to be comedy but craft
whatever that craft happens to be i
think you're a real
exemplar of just doing the work but
doing it is also a systematic
way which is a particular species
of working that i think makes a
beautiful case study
and this has been so much fun for me i i
really appreciate you taking the time
jerry thanks it was
i love talking with you tim and and your
podcast is the best
oh thanks so much it really makes my day
to have the chance to have a
conversation with you i've had the
bass riff from seinfeld going through my
head all day
and in prep for this and it's a real
gift
that you're showcasing and sharing
your notes with the world over such a
period of time i mean it is
i think something that will really
provide you know
like you said just work but nonetheless
will provide so much
so much help to an inspiration to people
who are
just setting out unlike the 43 year old
8 foot sturgeons those 15 year olds
and 15 to 20 year olds
and i will uh let you get back
to your day but this has been great and
please do let me know if i can help
in any way or with anything else oh it's
been a great pleasure tim
great pleasure and thank you for the
kind words it's um
much appreciated absolutely and to
everybody listening we'll have links to
everything including is this anything
in the show notes as per usual at
team.log forward slash podcast
and until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend so if you want to receive
that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
rock form that's without a c r o k f o
r m rokform is the active lifestyle
iphone and galaxy protective case
company i've been using their stuff for
a few months now
and good god they can survive anything
first off
rokform protection is beyond great you
can find thousands of five star reviews
and customer testimonials which the team
at rock farm calls survival stories that
include
things like a drop from the upper deck
of a baseball stadium and a 75 foot cell
phone tower fall
it's kind of unbelievable but these
cases make your phone
virtually indestructible each case is
built also around an integrated magnet
that is completely safe for your phone
the magnets are incredibly strong and
allow you to instantly attach your
device to any magnetic surface
toolboxes file cabinets refrigerators
golf carts
you name it i use it in the gym to check
my form a lot of the time you just
slap it on just about anything rokform
pioneered magnetic technology in the
mobile accessory space in 2011
and i've never seen anything quite like
these magnets
i will use mine on my peloton bike so i
can watch listen and take calls during
workouts
it fits my iphone 11 pro max perfectly
and allows me to keep my hands free for
all sorts of stuff all their cases also
come with a built-in twist lock system
that can be used with any of rokfarm's
optional mounts
for bike motorcycle car and much more
these machined aluminum mounts are built
to last and are compatible with every
rokform case
so if you get a new phone or whatever
you just need a new
case and it will still attach to all of
the mounts
rokform also has a portable golf speaker
this is bluetooth
that instantly mounts to a golf cart
with mind-blowingly
strong magnets like i mentioned i don't
really golf
but i will use this bluetooth speaker to
listen to music
in the kitchen slap it on the
refrigerator i will
use it in the gym and hang it from a
carabiner which is included
with the speaker and so on and so forth
so
upgrade to a rokform case today because
you have better things to hold onto you
can use your hands for other stuff
and like i mentioned these things make
your phone bulletproof
and as a special offer for tim ferriss
show listeners that's you guys
get 25 off that is a good discount 25
off at rockform.com that's rokform.com
when you use promo code tim that's 25
off
at rokform.com when you use promo code
tim one more time rockform.com promo
code
tim this episode is brought to you by
aura o-u-r-a it is the only wearable
that i wear on a daily basis aura is the
company
behind the smart ring that delivers
personalized sleep and health insights
to help you optimize
just about everything and i've tried
every device
out there that you can imagine this one
really
makes the cut i've been using it
religiously for at least six months now
and i was introduced to it by dr peter
etia who's also vetted
just about everything with advanced
sensors four packs state-of-the-art
heart rate heart rate variability
hrv super important to me temperature
activity and sleep
monitoring technology into a convenient
non-invasive
ring it's tiny it weighs less than six
grams and focuses on
three key insights sleep readiness and
activity so
i can use it to help focus my attention
on the type
volume intensity of exercise that i
should do in a given day
i use it to determine how certain types
of alcohol
at different times of the day affect my
sleep which they do and i can see all of
that
in graph form trended over time there
are tons of actionable insights that
have come from using this ring
for me they have a number of incredible
people on
their team dr matthew walker a professor
of neuroscience and psychology at uc
berkeley
and also author of why we sleep the mega
hit
is ora's chief science advisor as just
one example
the aura ring is one of the most
accurate wearables
available because it measures your
vitals directly from your finger
so it's not deducing that or
making a best guesstimate based on a
bunch of other things and trying to
triangulate
compared to a medical grade
electrocardiogram the oral ring is
99.9 accurate for resting heart rate
and 98.4 accurate for heart rate
variability and i work with hrv doctors
and they recommend
that i use the aura ring so try it
yourself it is
super cool and super practical very
actionable
the aura ring comes in two styles and
three colors
silver black and matte black i use matte
black
for 299 you can give or get
the gift of health by visiting
auraring.com
that's o-u-r-a-r-i-n-g
dot com again that's aura ring.com
you